[Musica]
buonasera
grazie mille per essere qui devo dire
che sono un po spaventato perché dopo il
delfino empatico farsi 18 minuti di
filosofia non è facile
resistete alla tentazione di scappare vi
prometto che sarà interessante
prima di venire qui stavo discutendo il
talk con una mia amica ridotto il titolo
nel titolo è l'intelligenza artificiale
e design intelligente ma l'empatia che
centra due giorni dopo stavamo ancora
discutendo su la rilevanza o meno
dell'empatia vi prometto che in 18
minuti ce la dovremo fare oggi
ma se lo faccio bene l'empatia sarà una
delle ultime parole che pronunciò questo
in questo talk perché sarà parte della
risposta a questa domanda che cosa
significa essere umani se le macchine
sono intelligenti una domanda un po
superficiale semplice in realtà quello
che è interessante di questa domanda che
è un po nella descrizione di questo
evento di oggi è che in realtà è un po
tendenziosa perché sembra assumere che
le macchine siano intelligenti e che se
lo sono sono intelligenti come gli
esseri umani realtà il sen questa
domanda ha una funzione fondamentale
dobbiamo domandarci se davvero le
macchine siano intelligenti se lo sono
che intelligenza hanno quindi io
inizierò questo toro che dicendo vi
appunto parlandomi un po di che cos'è
una intelligenza artificiale la
definiamo capire quali sono i rischi e
le opportunità che questa tecnologia ci
presenta che dobbiamo evitare o cogliere
puoi capire come questi rischi e
opportunità abbiano un impatto su esseri
umani al giorno d'oggi si parla
intelligenza artificiale le posizioni
sono diversissime abbiamo un range
ampissimo da una parte troviamo quelli
che dicono hanno intelligenza
artificiale fantastica cifra superiore
ai limiti biologici potremmo vivere per
sempre potremmo diventare immortali
faremo una cosa che si chiama il mind
uploading prendere tutte le informazioni
che sono nel nostro cervello e
trasferirle in una macchina che sarà
così potente da diventare un avatar
noi senza il corpo saremo veramente
potentissimi intelligentissimi e terni
dall'altra parte dello spettro ci sono
dicono hanno l'intelligenza artificiale
le macchine saranno sempre più potenti
sempre più raffinate saranno in grado di
definire le regole della loro
progettazione e diventeranno così
potenti così raffinate da rendere alla
specie umana una specie superfluo cis
termineranno c imprigioneranno ci
faranno schiavi
ecco la singolarità con la singularity
transione science fiction niente a che
fare con la ricerca niente a che fare
con la scienza
se vi capita di sentire qualcuno che vi
dice una di queste due cose è un bel
libro una bella discussione per il pub e
il venerdì sera niente a che fare con la
realtà che abbiamo davanti
l'intelligenza artificiale questa è la
definizione un po accademica però è
l'unica cosa veramente accademica di
questo tour quindi abbiate pazienza è
una risorsa di agenti autonomi capace di
interagire e di imparare e che possono
essere usati per eseguire compiti che
altrimenti richiederebbero
l'intelligenza umana per essere seguiti
con successo l'abbiamo definita così in
un paper che abbiamo pubblicato l'anno
scorso in science robotics ci sono due
cose che sono importanti in questa
definizione
la prima ci dice che tipo di
intelligenza hanno le macchine le
macchine non sono intelligenti non hanno
idee non hanno intuizioni non hanno
empatia non hanno consapevolezza non
hanno coscienza non hanno intuizioni
come quelle che possiamo vedere noi
quando stiamo facendo la cosa più
semplice le macchine si comportano come
se fossero intelligente regolare la
temperatura di questo teatro a seconda
della temperatura esterna di come
reagiscono le persone dentro il teatro
se lo facessi io beh voi penserete
rovente di gente ha capito che avevamo
freddo alzato il termostato la macchina
lo fa lo stesso raggiungere lo stesso
obiettivo ma non è intelligente ha un
comportamento che noi definiremmo
intelligente sia un essere umano lo
stesso seguendo l'altro aspetto che è
importante che l'intelligenza
artificiale ci permette di avere agenti
che sono autonomi e capaci di interagire
e di imparare mentre interagiscono con
l'ambiente non è nella storia
dell'umanità abbiamo avuto un macchine
automatiche alloggio che portiamo al
polso certi tipi di macchine ma mai
macchine autonome ed è questa autonomia
che non è quella degli esseri umani che
crea i problemi i rischi ma anche le
opportunità che l'intelligenza
artificiale ci presenta oggi vi parlo
un po dei rischi ma voglio realtà
parlare di più di cose positive quindi
le opportunità il primo rischio a che
fare con il profiling avrete sentito ne
hanno parlato gli speakers prima di me è
quello che permette a google di farci
avere informazioni che sono simili o
vicini a quelle che noi veramente
stavamo cercando quando abbiamo aperto
la pagina
io sono napoletana se cerca un
ristorante a londra nella di sera
la prima cosa che vedo sono pizzerie ma
sia fammi vedere un costante di sushi
potrei avere una crisi isterica google
lo sa e quindi previene la situazione
profiling è una cosa buona
fino a quando non diventa ragioni di
discriminazione
quando perde tra quelli che sono i
pregiudizi che nella società già ci sono
e che l'intelligenza artificiale
facilità
un altro esempio annegato a google e
alcuni anni fa è diventato famoso il
caso in cui mostrava l'algoritmo di
google avvisi pubblicitari per lavori
manageriali più spesso agli utenti
uomini che agli utenti donne è un caso
di discriminazione
questo è un rischio che dobbiamo evitare
perché una società in cui l'intelligenza
artificiale sarà sempre più distribuita
non possiamo permetterci che si
facilitano e si distribuiscano si
moltiplichino questi tipi di
discriminazione secondo problema a che
fare con la natura di questa tecnologia
molto spesso le aie definita come una
black box una scatola nera cioè noi
abbiamo gli input disegniamo la
tecnologia ma non possiamo predire gli
output potremmo certo avendo lo stesso
capacità stessa capacità di computazione
ma è difficile e questo perché è
importante ma è importante perché noi ci
fidiamo delle ai deleghiamo alle ai
compiti importantissimi la diagnosi del
cancro decidere chi assumere mo al
prossimo concorso di lavoro a prossimo
colloquio di lavoro che ristorante
andare nella di sera
in realtà però ci fidiamo di queste
macchine che non comprendiamo e di cui
non possiamo non di cui non abbiamo
predicibilità nel comportamento e anche
questo è un aspetto importante c'è tanta
ricerca che si focalizza su questo
argomento e l'altro aspetto a che fare
con l'uso delle high e l'impatto
sull'essere umano abbiamo sentito prima
la quarta rivoluzione no è una quarta
rivoluzione industriale è una frase che
ricorre spesso è la si usa per indicare
il fatto che siamo diventati società
digitali in realtà la quarta la
rivoluzione industriale non è tanto il
fatto che troviamo gli amici su facebook
che copriamo libri su amazon è più il
fatto che il nostro frigo fa la spesa su
amazon avendo capito quello che ci piace
sulla base dei commenti che scriviamo su
facebook e questa correlazione
eccole ai facilità questa correlazione è
un facilitatore invisibile che media tra
le interazioni le nostre azioni con
l'ambiente e nel mediare in realtà un po
ci dà degli indirizzi a che punto questi
indirizzi sono in contraddizione con la
nostra autodeterminazione con la nostra
capacità di scegliere il mio lavoro in
parte anche essere sicuri che
utilizziamo leale ai a supporto della
nostra determinazione non contro o a
discapito della stessa vi ho detto
appunto non solo sono rischi sono anche
opportunità il grande vantaggio delle
high e che ci permette di delegare
compiti che sono tediosi noiosi a volte
pericolosi alle macchine e ci libera
tempo in inghilterra non tutti abbiamo
un giardino d'estate vorremmo fare delle
feste ma non si arriva mai
sabato sera con la voglia di fare perché
hai speso tutta la giornata a tagliare
il prato e qualche tempo fa ho cambiato
casa ho speso un weekend a montare i
mobili di che a liti che non si potevano
neanche male posso descrivere non c'è
una sedia che sia in equilibrio a casa
mia quando ho scoperto che c'erano robot
guidati dalle ai che potevano assemblare
i mobili che ha da sola e ho avuto un
momento di commozione anche inenarrabile
e così guidare nelle zone trafficate
invece di spendere tempo guidare poter
leggere o interagire e via dicendo
in una società in cui le aie sarà
distribuito in maniera orizzontale sarà
dovunque nelle nostre tasche sui
cellulari nel nostro tostapane nel
nostro termostato in ospedale a scuola
in ufficio
il compito essere sicuri che piu e ai
significhi più human flash e cioè la
capacità di sviluppare e realizzare i
nostri progetti esistenziali i nostri
progetti umani sia a livello individuale
sia a livello sociale nel 2015 la m ha
definito quelli che si chiamano
the wall dei vermi agosto sono 17 sfide
che dobbiamo raggiungere con successo
entro il 2030 che permetteranno
l'umanità di vivere meglio di fare
meglio di stare meglio e vanno da vino e
la birra ricerca nell'ambito biomedico
la cura della salute la protezione
dell'ambiente la parità di genere
la diversità abbiamo scoperto abbiamo
capito che l'intelligenza artificiale
può aiutare e facilitare lo sviluppo di
tutti questi obiettivi ci sono
applicazioni delle ai che permettono dei
contadini in india di capire quando
seminare per massimizzare il raccolto
date le condizioni climatiche abbiamo
applicazione delle ai che facilitano la
raccolta delle plastiche dagli oceani
che una delle tragedie ambientaliste
forse più sentiti al giorno d'oggi
sappiamo che nel 2050 ci saranno 131
milioni di persone malate di alzheimer
una malattia che non possiamo curare che
è difficile da diagnosticare e abbiamo
capito che le ha in ci permette di
anticipare la diagnosi di sei anni
limitando così l'impatto della malattia
perché possiamo curare la prima allora
com'è che tutte questi rischi tutte
queste opportunità come è come ci
impattano come come ci affliggono in
quanto esseri esseri umani risposta che
mi hanno spesso e questa è una frase
leonardo da vinci che dice sono stato
impressionato dall urgenza del fare
sapere non è abbastanza dobbiamo agire
avere ottime intenzioni non basta
dobbiamo fare e uno davanti alle
potenzialità delle ai è davvero preso
dalla voglia dire beh allora
sfruttiamole non ce ne perdiamo cambiamo
il mondo
a leggerla anche un po superficiale nero
superficialmente sembra quasi di leggere
uno di quei moti della silicon valley
qualche anno fa a san francisco
avrebbero detto fail ostenfeld fast non
ti preoccupare se sbagli libri ripeti lo
sbaglio l'importante che ti riprendi e
riprovi e continuo a provare prima o poi
fai le cose fatte bene nel processo
abbiamo avuto cambridge analitica
abbiamo avuto tutti gli scandali di cui
abbiamo sentito quindi non è proprio una
buona idea in realtà leonardo non ci sta
dicendo fail ostenfeld fast leonardo è
un uomo del rinascimento e un uomo
poetico se il suo fare
segue al pensare e utilizzare lo
strumento di oggi per cambiare domani il
fare significa progettare in realtà ce
lo dice ci dice la conoscenza non è
abbastanza
e necessaria ma non
se non è di una sufficiente le buone
intenzioni servono ma non bastano
bisogna fare di più ma ci vogliono
allora quali sono le buone intenzioni
quali sono le conoscenze che ci servono
al giorno d'oggi per poter fare come
avrebbe voluto leonardo cioè progettare
il futuro
e qui arriva un altro po di filosofia ma
è veramente poca
lei è una tecnologia
forse una delle più avanzate la più
avanzata del digitale e il digitale una
tecnologia rivoluzionaria non solo
perché ci permette di fare cose nuove ma
perché nel farlo cambia la realtà
intorno a noi è una tecnologia
trasformativa col digitale facciamo
nuove cose appunto potremo leggere un
libro mentre guidiamo ma cambia anche il
modo in cui capiamo le cose pensate al
concetto di guerra è una delle aree in
cui lavoro molto io la guerra nella
strada e l'umanità significato violenza
distruzione morte il giorno parliamo di
saper con fritz di conflitti cibernetici
che sono sì una espressione di forza
sono sia un'espressione di di
aggressività ma sono completamente
staccati al concetto di violenza
possiamo combattere una guerra
cibernetica senza uccidere nessuno senza
distruggere niente eppure raggiungere lo
stesso obiettivo è cambiato un concetto
quello di guerra che era un concetto che
equivaleva forza e violenza è diventato
un concetto in cui invece la violenza è
staccata da quello di forza questa
trasformazione dell'ambiente delle
nostre interazioni della nostra
comprensione che digitale le hai fanno
sono la leva sono l'elemento sul quale
dobbiamo spingere per capire in realtà
per per per fare quel per raggiungere
quel fare che leonardo ci ci suggerisce
qual è quindi la natura o il valore
dell'essere umano nella società del
digitale nella società dove le macchine
si comportano come se fossero
intelligenti e noi possiamo delegare
alle hai il potere computazionale
l'intelligenza artificiale può
raccogliere informazioni elaborare
informazioni fare correlazioni una
maniera più veloce più precisa di
qualsiasi altra intelligenza noi
conosciamo
immaginate la diagnosi del cancro
intelligenza artificiale può riconoscere
da un attacco un cancro senza mai
stancarsi senza mai dimenticarsi nessuna
delle tac che ha visto prima senza avere
un momento di stress un momento di paura
è super efficiente ma questa è la delega
lei è uno strumento uno strumento che
dobbiamo utilizzare per cambiare la
realtà in cui viviamo
dobbiamo utilizzare le hai per
progettare le società la nostra società
ma anche quelle che si chiamano la
società poste ai cioè quelle società
nelle quali lea e non sarà più una
tecnologia trasformativa rivoluzionarie
ma sarà data un po come la corrente
elettrica al giorno a nostro agio nei
nostri dobbiamo utilizzare le aree per
essere sicuri di sviluppare società che
siano tolleranti che siano giuste anche
siano democratiche che siano più
realiste l'ordine delle parole non è
casuale tolleranza è un valore
fondamentale in questo contesto
allora se guardiamo al design
intelligente perché è importante perché
il design intelligente intelligente alla
maniera di leonard dirigente alla
maniera della della progettazione del
futuro è quello che ci fa umani e la
cosa che le ha e non fa perché noi
facciamo e abbiamo la responsabilità di
farlo perché si tratta di dare la forma
alla realtà che seguirà quella dei
nostri figli
io vi lascio con una citazione di
winston churchill che era uno anche
abbastanza cinico però ci vedeva molto
bene e per quanto riguardava il futuro
una volta ha detto qui shapour buildings
and building 6 pass andiamo noi una
forma ai nostri palazzi però poi palazzi
danno una forma a noi
l'architettura ci dice questo
questa frase vera per l'architettura è
ancora più vera per il digitale è ancora
più vero per le hai noi disegniamo le
hai noi progettiamo le hai e dobbiamo
sapere che questa tecnologia poi ha un
impatto molto diretto e molto forte su
noi come persone sono e come società se
noi come ambiente allora dobbiamo essere
sicuri di progettare le hai in modo tale
che ci permetta di acquisire la forma
che vogliamo per una forma in cui
l'empatia rimane un valore fondamentale
un aspetto da curare da proteggere e da
distribuire e con questo vi ringrazio
[Applauso]